all right here are some of the questions
from the Internet's it's Sarah Palin's
birthday today do you have any special
wishes for her I don't think even on HBO
do you think she understands that it's
her birthday I don't I think they said
Sarah it's your birthday and she thought
her water broke happy brush she's 47 47
yeah well god bless the god bless ya
know do you think Donald Trump could
become a viable Republican presidential
candidate following his CPAC performance
I heard he sort of stole the show yeah I
don't think he's running for president I
think he's running for more attention
he's hired for that well I don't know
you know I saw him on the news doing
this I mean of course he was completely
full of himself
you know just telling him how wonderful
he is I'm a winner I've you know all
this accomplishment I went to the best
business school it was just nauseating
we just can't have a comb-over president
we just yeah you can have a bald one but
yeah not a coma not that thing on his
head right but yeah but you know what he
he the TV no the event Ron Paul people
who always kind of packed that
convention started to boo when he said
you know that he can't win and he does
have the balls I think unlike a lot of
Republican candidates to talk to those
people like shut up
and you know know your place as opposed
to the cast kissing that most of the
Republicans do I think Donald Trump I'm
telling you I think he could do great
with the debates be if Donald Trump was
in the debates well how about if it was
Trump Sarah Palin to reality show stars
that would say a lot about
America as the truth bill you say you're
not a Democrat but you can you name any
Republican you would even consider for
voting for for president this is the
question I asked all right yeah that's I
mean I always liked Colin Powell but
he's not running I mean there were used
to be some Schwarzenegger I like but he
can't you know but again it's not my
fault is the fact that there's you know
this Republican Party has become a party
of you know insane people I mean there's
no moderates yes if there was the
old-school Republicans I absolutely
wouldn't have yeah
come on Lincoln Republicans what Lincoln
Lincoln came back from the dead
you would support him of course him back
to the dead he wouldn't be a Republican
yeah I mean anybody asks back from the
dead they should be President
[Applause]
this is what I meant when I said he's in
the part that doesn't count consult the
internet this is the part that counts
the most
Oh after seeing the peaceful
demonstrations in Egypt that finally
toppled Mubarak today will Americans
finally come to stand that Egyptians
Arabs Gyptian / Arab / Muslims are not
inherently violent yeah I think we know
that that was one of the the greatest
things and the president mentioned that
today that this was the moral force of
non-violence
it was truly striking and Egypt being a
model for other countries that want to
move forward democracy they said to that
wonderful woman we had on last week Mona
who I saw a number of shows this week I
still do not think it is representative
of the 80 million Egyptian people I
think it's the more well-to-do more
educated you know yeah who were in the
square revolutions are rarely
representative of all the people Russian
Revolution wasn't the French Revolution
wasn't it's very rare that a revolution
as a representative of all the people
and both those revolutions got hijacked
by the right-wing
war and the Iranian Revolution some
people argue that although the Iranian
Revolution was actually probably a 1979
revolution was very popular at least
over over 80 percent I would say and I
suppose people would say the Russian
Revolution was hijacked by the left-wing
but I think when you go that far left
and it's like a circle you're really the
right what's a circle
I get there I consider Lenin and Stalin
right-wingers don't tell Rush Limbaugh's
all right at a time thank you very much
folks you did terrific